l'a1 scegliete di ghirardi buon natale e
un felice anno nuovo
prendine stringile tra mali e poi le
balle se questo mano ti ha fatto
soffrire bene prima o poi dovrà subire
cenere e polvere su questo marche
che voglia di scopa
6 20 20 te la messa su
[Musica]
si dà la vita
ciao
[Musica]
questo nadal è una merda può entrare
nelle vostre case di spiegarmi d'albero
con un bastone
il mio l'ho già sprecato i ramoscelli
hanno fatto crik crok chiamatemi se ne
avete bisogno è gratis
cazzo cazzo
un cazzo
bosco
[Musica]
tu
il porto
[Musica]
terrore
questo lato
lo sai
[Musica]
le visti bene
per la v
ma non d
popper
il cuore peggio
ok
la mia
altri fondi ha spiegato
[Musica]
e se non c'è un caso o per vacan
una voce trova il ha vinto nero sono pur
sempre trasformista e suo amato nati
nero
[Applauso]
poca banda da banca a banca a banca
[Musica]
[Applauso]